- Fini les cabanes brunes
le long de nos grandes routes
au Québec.
FRANCOIS BONNARDEL, ministre
des Transports, Québec
- S'il y a une chose qui me
rendait pas très fier dans
les dernnées quand on a
à voyager partout sur
le territoire québecois, c'est
nos fameuses cabanes brunes,
nos haltes routières. Pas très
fier parce que ces haltes, qui
ont été baties dans les années
60-70, n'ont pas recu beaucoup
d'amour.
- En voici une le long de
l'autoroute 20 en mauvais état.
Une halte fermée en raison d'un
me d'alimentation en eau.
Pas d'eau potable donc et
des toilettes chimiques
à l'extérieur.
Vous, ça vous dérange?
- C'est comme le pcomme le pcom.
(rire)
- Au québec, c'est comme ça.
Les haltes routières, il y ajams
c'est pas trop propre, mais on
pourrait avoir mieux que ça.
- C'est désagréable d'aller dans
les toilettes d'à coté.
- Les toilettes chimiques, il
n'y a pas de lavabo, donc c'est?
- Exact avec la pandémie, là.
- Mais c'est en fait avec
l'argents qu'on pait en impôt,
ça pourrait être mieux.
(rire)
- "Ce n'est pas un 5 étoiles",
nous dit cette touriste
ontarienne. Le gouvernement
du Québec vient de décider
d'investir 150 millions
de dollars étalés sur 5 ans pour
améliorer les haltes routières.
Le gouvernement coment
y ajouter des installations
sanitaires modernes avec
des salles d'allaitement et
des tables à langer.
Le ministre des Transports veut
également assurer une meilleure
sécurité dans ces lieux publics
et souhaite interdire certainess
activités, disons ilicites, qui
se déroulent dans plusieurs
haltes routières au Québec.
- Si on doit avoir un agent ou
des agents de sécurité sur ces
haltes pour des situations que
vous connaissez, des services
"x" que vous connaissez,
on le fera.
- Les travaux de modernisation
des haltes routières doivent
commencer sous peu, mais un peu
tard pour les vacances
estivales.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Ste-Madeleine